[Musique]
je suis en mesure de vous donner le sexe
de l'enfant si vous le souhaitez donc si
on vote dans un échange sais pas je
crois que j'aimerais bien savoir quoi
enfin ça donne des trucs que vous voulez
la gare aux fausses et ça vous fait
plaisir
je couche juste savoir pourquoi tu
commence une histoire maintenant avec un
mec qu'on connaissait ni d'eve ni d'adam
il ya encore trois mois et qu'on verra
plus dans deux ans et n'a jamais gardé
avec plus de quinze jours dans ta vie tu
t'excuses s'il te plaît arrête toi tu
pense la même chose
jackie chan il en pense quoi de ta
grossesse bah ils acceptent puisqu'il
est là comment tu vas pouvoir temps
c'est pareil comme ça d'un claquement de
doigts du coup tu parles il n'y a pas de
raisons tu crois vraiment ce que tu dis
et oui vraiment c'est exactement comme
ça que je veux que ce soit moi j'ai du
mal à le croire
j'ai jamais eu envie d'un enfant c'est
pas comme moi donc tu déteste être
enceinte tu regrettes mais ça n'a rien à
voir
être enceinte et avoir un enfant ça n'a
rien à voir et comment tu le sais
puisque tours n'a jamais eu mais je sais
puisque je le vis tu lui as dit pour tes
seins parce que va lui faire un choc en
titre
un comic book dérange pas si j'arrive à
séparer ma tête me vendre à bon mari du
coup je fais avec quels partis des
cherche pas
[Musique]